welcome back to my channel this is the
second video from the series how to get
your shots
more filmic so this picture was shot
in an old abandoned hospital
uh this is the before
and this is the after this is a super
super easy uh edit
it's going to be super fast so
as always i go to the details tab bring
the sharpening all the way down
luminance
pretty much all the way down because
this was shot at iso 100
so no problem uh details all the way
down single pixel all the way up
because it's underexposed like
a loads like extremely underexposed
as we can see here and we need to bring
a little bit of that detail back
cool actually i'm going to show you the
difference
like before the single pixel
and afterwards okay so uh brightness a
little bit up
like so something like that okay a
little bit more of the shadows
just like so cool and now
let's crush the whites so we level it up
okay maybe more of the yeah good
now let's let's zoom in okay let's zoom
in
right here actually this is pretty clean
so
we might not see much of a difference
with a single pixel effect let's bring
it all the way up
yeah okay there is pretty much no
difference in that
let's bring the luminance all the way
down cool i think the most important
the most uh important and powerful uh
slider in the noise reduction
is actually the color so if i bring the
color all the way down you can see
how uh each pixel starts breaking apart
and
they're like different spots of of
colors and hues everywhere like green
magenta blue whatever so if i
turn it back on to 50 it just
does magic it's awesome cool
okay make it a little bit more moody
let's work with the midtones a little
bit yeah
let's bring the black point up a little
bit okay then
maybe less exposure like bring down the
exposure
something like that maybe a little
maybe just a little bit more contrast
exactly like
so cool
let's go to the color tab and
i'll bring the tint to more of a
greenish
look okay more
green more blue and then in the
highlights i'll
just give more green maybe
somewhere around there take it down a
little bit
cool and uh i'll i'll add a little bit
more red
in the shadows
to give it more of a nostalgic
so that's it we'll add some film grain
to it
to look more filmic a little bit
silver rich grain maybe like that i like
it
okay cool maybe a little bit more
granularity
granularity okay
i think that's fine yeah so
this is the before this is after super
easy super fast
i hope you liked it subscribe like
and i hope to see you in the next one
see ya